tom brady considerado el mejor jugador
de la historia de la nfl ha anunciado a
través de sus redes sociales que deja el
deporte profesional se retira con un
palmarés de siete anillos de la
superbowl la final de la liga de fútbol
americano de eeuu que acapara la
atención de todo el planeta cada año en
los últimos días había una gran
incertidumbre precisamente porque había
muchas dudas sobre la continuidad de tom
brady en la nfl el deportista de los
tampa bay de 44 años quedó eliminado
junto a su equipo tras perder contra los
ángeles rams lo que significaba que tom
brady no iba a disputar una nueva super
bowl desde ese momento los rumores
sonaron con más fuerza pero no ha sido
hasta esta mañana que la estrella de la
nfl ha confirmado que color a su casco
las razones de su retirada estarían en
que su rendimiento ha bajado y no está
al ciento por ciento y porque afirman
los entrenadores fans y compañeros
también merecen que él esté dando lo
mejor de sí dice que en los últimos 22
años como jugador de la nfl siempre ha
ido con la filosofía de que el deporte
es un todo o nada su adiós ha recibido
el reconocimiento del mundo del deporte
no solo del fútbol americano que han
elogiado su brillante carrera y la
historia que deja para la nfl